merci Rémi Féraud nous accompagner
pendant cette première demi-heure cette
sénateur socialiste de Paris on va
évidemment parler de l'agenda du Sénat
de la réforme des retraites mais d'abord
on l'a vu l'actualité ces dernières
heures du côté du Brésil ou des milliers
de partisans de l'ancien président
d'extrême droite giant bolsonaro ont
envahi des lieux de pouvoir le Congrès
la Cour suprême le palais présidentielle
envahit saccagé il refuse de reconnaître
l'élection de Lula en fonction depuis
une semaine que pensez-vous de ces
images et de ses attitudes
ces images sont particulièrement
éprouvantes elle rappelle tellement et
pile deux ans après les images du
Congrès américain Washington elle nous
rappelle que l'extrême droite est un
danger pour la démocratie que l'extrême
droite n'accepte le résultat des urnes
que quand il lui est favorable et que
l'extrême droite veut empêcher les
peuples de choisir librement leur
dirigeants leurs orientations politique
quand cela ne leur convient pas cette
diffusion du populisme dans le monde est
évidemment un sujet qui doit continuer
de nous préoccuper
en Amérique mais aussi en Europe bien
sûr parce que on voit que ce qui s'est
passé à Washington s'est reproduit à
Brasilia et peut se produire ailleurs
même si les situations politiques et
puis aussi l'organisation des forces de
sécurité sont différentes dans chacun de
nos pays et l'attitude aussi parce que
là j'ai révoltonaro a condamné dans les
premières heures je cite les
déprédations et l'invasion de bâtiments
publics c'est une bonne chose c'est ton
condamnation
c'est une condamnation à minima d'un
ancien président très lâche qui s'est
réfugié enfin presque mis à l'abri aux
États-Unis dirait-on mais qui en même
temps et largement derrière ces
manifestations et se refus du résultat
c'est vraiment la conclusion de toute sa
campagne et toute sa présidence le
mimétisme avec Donald Trump est
tellement fort qu'il en est
voilà tellement évident pour pour tout
le monde ce qui est important c'est
aussi que l'ensemble des grands
responsables politiques des pays
démocratiques dans le monde disent
qu'ils sont attachés aux résultats
démocratiques au Brésil et à la
stabilité des institutions je crois que
ça c'est très important l'autre
actualité de ces dernières heures ce
sont ses propos de Noël le grecte le
patron du foot français qui a vivement
attaqué Zinédine Zidane disons qu'il
n'en a rien à secouer et que si elles
Zinédine Zidane l'avait appelé il ne
l'aurait même pas pris au téléphone
est-ce que ce sont des propos dignes
d'un patron de la FFF non je crois
qu'ils ont choqué tous les Français donc
j'imagine que étant de tourner la page
aussi à la Fédération Française de foot
c'est-à-dire une démissionné pour vous
oh je crois que c'est un peu inéluctable
bah moi de dire comme ça mais je crois
que c'était un peu inéluctable en tout
cas je sais que c'est pour pousser vers
la sortie oui je crois que c'est propos
il se posent tout seul là avec ses
propos vers la sortie ses propos je suis
sur un choqué tous les Français
on va parler de l'actualité politique et
la réforme des retraites et Eric
ciotique donc hier déclaré dans le
Journal du Dimanche que les républicains
sont donc en clés enclin à voter cette
réforme des retraites est-ce que du coup
vous avez perdu le combat au Parlement
pas du tout non parce qu'on va le mener
on n'a pas encore eu les annonces
du gouvernement se croisait demain enfin
fait longtemps qu'on les attend ensuite
de toute façon depuis le départ le
gouvernement fait planer la menace du
49-3 49-3 qu'il avait d'ailleurs déjà
failli utiliser il y a trois ans de cela
maintenant puisque exactement qui a été
interrompu brutalement par l'arrivée du
covid donc vous voyez l'histoire n'est
jamais écrite donc nous on va mener ce
combat en lien avec le mouvement social
c'est plutôt le gouvernement qui
aujourd'hui est complètement dans la
main des républicains et les
républicains qui cherchent aussi comment
avoir une expression politique qui soit
différente celle du gouvernement je
crois que c'est un peu parce que les
Français en retiennent mais je crois
qu'ils retiennent surtout que le
gouvernement et la droite LR sont sur
des positions extrêmement proches voir
similaire la une du JDD hier était très
éclairante quand on pense je crois que
c'est plutôt quand même un problème pour
ceux qui se disaient macroniste de
gauche quand reste-t-il aujourd'hui
quand on en est à dire mais monsieur
ciotivoter pour notre réforme c'est la
même que celle que vous portiez dans la
campagne présidentielle ce qui est
largement vrai voilà c'est le
gouvernement qui aujourd'hui mène une
politique de droite et va proposer une
réforme injuste des retraites à un
moment où le pays aurait besoin d'unités
et d'autres ambitions c'est ça la
réalité est-ce que pour mener cette
réforme de retraite il ne faut pas être
uni du côté des socialistes parce qu'on
a l'impression qu'il y a des divergences
en votre sein vous vous êtes pour la
retraite à 60 ans ou à 62 ans moi je
suis contre la réforme que va proposer
le gouvernement demain à moins qu'il en
change totalement l'esprit mais je n'y
crois pas c'est à dire le report de
l'âge légal de la retraite vous êtes
pour maintien 62 ans je ne suis contre
cette réforme et je ne suis pas pour le
retour à la retraite à 60 ans sinon je
pense que c'est une fausse piste pour
s'opposer efficacement à la réforme
injuste que nous propose que va nous
proposer
c'est un problème c'était dans le
programme de la nuque ce printemps oui
dans un compromis je ne partage pas
je ne partage pas en tout cas
personnellement cette position politique
c'était un accord électoral au printemps
dernier la nups n'a pas gagné les
élections législatives donc il est temps
à mon avis on est dans une nouvelle
étape politique et ce qu'il faut c'est
s'opposer efficacement au projet du
gouvernement
avec les syndicats qui à l'unanimité
sont contre il ne s'agit pas de d'autre
chose dans cette période politique là
sauf que la réforme de marées sol
Touraine portait donc par un
gouvernement socialiste elle prévoit
déjà l'allongement du nombre d'amités à
43utés du coup est-ce que c'est pas un
peu hypocrite de la part des socialistes
de s'opposer un report de l'âge de légal
de départ est-ce que de toute façon il
ne va pas de soi quand il faudra faire
40 années 40
d'un allongement de la durée de
cotisation très progressif et étalée
dans le temps donc non non là on est
au-delà d'une accélération parce qu'en
plus la réforme Touraine ne change pas
l'âge légal de départ en retraite est-ce
que c'est vraiment ce dont le pays a
besoin aujourd'hui alors que le régime
des retraites était excédentaire en 2022
c'est ça la réalité est-ce qu'il y a pas
autre chose à faire dans notre pays les
républicains berger pour Renaissance
demande que la retraite minimum à 1200
euros s'applique également pour les
retraités actuels et non pas seulement
pour les futurs retraités comme le
prévoit le gouvernement et ceux là
dessus vous soutiendrez ce combat c'est
que la réalité c'est que le projet du
gouvernement ne le prévoit pas
contrairement à des engagements qui
semblent avoir été pris dans ou qui ont
été entendu mais espérons que ça change
mais c'est pas
nous nous inscrirons pas dans la logique
du gouvernement de report de l'âge légal
de la retraite soyons clairs on va
continuer à parler de l'actualité
économique l'actualité sociale on va
voir ça avec Arnaud vasige qu'on
retrouve du côté de Nantes bonjour
Arnaud merci
d'être avec nous directeur de la
publication de l'agence happy West
France vous suivez l'actualité
économique du Grand Ouest et Arnaud dans
l'Ouest comme partout en France il y a
deux nombreuses entreprises qui
souffrent de l'envoler des prix de
l'énergie tout à fait ouais elle se
média d'Ouessant suit l'actualité
économique de l'Ouest et recense chaque
semaine des exemples d'entreprises qui
souffrent de l'explosion des prix de
l'énergie on peut en citer quelques
exemples comme la fonderie bouillée qui
est installé depuis 100 ans près de
Nantes c'est quand même pas rien 100 ans
championne de l'export qu'on connu
mondialement et qui continue d'investir
mais qui pourrait voir sa facture
énergétique multipliée par 10 en 2023
plus dramatique l'entreprise slts qui
emploie 98 salariés dans le
Maine-et-Loire est placé elle en
redressement judiciaire par le tribunal
de commerce d'Angers l'explosion des
factures d'énergie a été pour elle de
plus 450% en 2022 ce qui est
considérable et puis un troisième
exemple celui du seul acteur en Bretagne
qui propose du frais de ferroviaire le
groupe René light global logistique qui
appelle à l'aide le gouvernement pour
l'aider à affronter une du prix
d'électricité en 2023 et elle pourrait
carrément remettre en question son
projet d'ouverture d'une nouvelle ligne
rail route entre Rennes et Lille cette
année
les entreprises qui s'adaptent à cette
hausse des prix de l'énergie et qui font
preuve d'agilité
oui tout à fait les entreprises de
l'Ouest ne manquent pas d'idées et
s'adapte par exemple des entreprises
vendéennes imagine ce regrouper en
profil de consommation pour permettre
des achats auprès des fournisseurs et
peser plus lourds d'autres comme la
conserverie good dans le Finistère sert
les dents mais reviennent sur leur
organisation du travail quitte à
travailler que quatre jours par semaine
en fin d'année pour faire justement des
économies d'énergie puis il y a aussi
cette entreprise du Maine-et-Loire NP
création qui s'apprête à couvrir 12000
m² de toiture en panneaux
photovoltaïques avec l'objectif
d'atteindre une production d'au moins
300000 kWh et un projet ainsi
l'autoconsommation alors certains font
même de la situation une occasion de
business Sherpa on Ille-et-Vilaine se
lance avec les flambées des prix dans la
récupération de données de consommation
pour proposer des comparatifs aux
entreprises à la sur pouvoir donner aux
dirigeants qui se perdent dans la
complexité des contrats un tableau de
bord pour leur permettre justement de
prendre des décisions éclairées alors du
côté du gouvernement les aides sont
nombreuses cette année en 2023 comme par
exemple LED aux entreprise les plus
énergivores ou l'amortisseur électricité
mais je voulais vous demander monsieur
le sénateur quel soutien serait selon
vous le plus efficace pour aider les PME
et est-ce qu'il y a pas une allègement
des complexités des dossiers à imaginer
pour que justement ces PME puisse s'y
retrouver dans la globalité des aides
qui sont proposés
alors si certainement il y a des
simplifications à effectuer nous nous le
disions cet automne dans le débat
budgétaire ce que proposait le
gouvernement et qui est nécessaire pour
soutenir les Français et les entreprises
en particulier les petites entreprises
les commerçants face à l'augmentation
des prix de l'énergie n'étaient pas
clair était largement improvisé nous ne
voulions pas nous y opposer mais nous
n'avions pas l'ensemble des éléments
pour en juger donc aujourd'hui il faut
pouvoir s'adapter rapidement et très
rapidement à
lorsqu'on voit qu'il y a des trous dans
la raquette et c'est depuis le mois de
décembre que nous interpellions je pense
notamment à Valérie rabot député
socialiste à l'Assemblée le gouvernement
sur la question des boulangers qui est
une activité qui est très consommatrice
d'énergie ça veut dire que le
gouvernement réagit trop tard pour vous
sur les boulangers
l'interpellait depuis cet automne j'ai
rencontré vendredi l'un
responsable de la Fédération des
boulangers de Paris nous a dit que
depuis le mois de septembre octobre ils
interpellaient le gouvernement sur leur
inquiétude et notamment pour ceux qui
ont une fin de contrat d'électricité ou
pour ceux qui sont toujours juste en
dessous au dessus des seuils qui ne
peuvent pas être aidés donc il faut
pouvoir évaluer la mise en place des
mesures et les adapter au fur et à
mesure je pense par exemple là
aujourd'hui il y a sur les boulangers un
seuil de 3% du l'énergie dans le chiffre
d'affaires pour pouvoir bénéficier un
certain nombre d'aides ce seuil est
certainement un peu trop élevé il faut
pouvoir voilà être souple être mobile ce
que Bercy n'est pas toujours donc bien
sûr que le Parlement pour évaluer les
dispositifs leur application interpeller
le gouvernement faire des propositions
et tout à fait essentielles
Arnaud un dernier mot regarde la une
non non est-ce que c'est mesures sont
suffisantes ou est-ce que vous
proposeriez par exemple une autre mesure
qui n'a pas été listée par le
gouvernement
aujourd'hui ces mesures n'apparaissent
pas suffisante sur un certain nombre de
professions et je pense notamment au
commerce de bouche à certains
restaurants aux entreprises qui sont
juste au dessus ou en dessous des seuils
s'il y a une proposition
urgente à faire je pense que c'est de
d'élargir les seuils de prise en compte
des dispositifs notamment de
l'amortisseur qui était un dispositif
d'aide supplémentaire par rapport au
bouclier tarifaire c'est peut-être ça le
plus urgent aujourd'hui nous disent les
professionnels merci si on regarde la
Une de Ouest-France réforme des
retraites les enjeux de la pénibilité
c'est à la Une de Ouest-France
aujourd'hui merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec nous Arnaud évidemment à très vite
alors la réforme des retraites c'est pas
pour tout de suite pour les sénateurs on
va regarder en revanche quels sont les
textes qui vont vous occuper ces
prochaines semaines c'est avec Alex ou
ça
[Musique]
bonjour Yann bonjour Rémy frérot bonjour
et Alex on va donc voir avec vous
l'agenda de ce mois de janvier au Sénat
mais oui alors cette année 2023 pour les
sénateurs elle va commencer et bien en
douceur avec un échauffement cette
semaine des débats à thématiques dans
l'hémicycle demain par exemple les
sénateurs des patrons des et des feux
les zones à faibles émissions
c'est-à-dire l'interdiction progressive
des véhicules polluants à l'intérieur
des agglomérations et puis demain il y
aura aussi un débat sur la rémunération
du travail c'est un débat à l'initiative
du groupe socialiste mercredi c'est un
sujet urgent qui va occuper à les
échanges entre les sénateurs dans
l'hémicycle la crise de notre système de
santé notamment après les dernières
annonces du président de la République
et puis jeudi à la demande du groupe
communiste un débat sur le marché de
l'électricité en période de tension sur
le marché de l'énergie puis dès la
semaine prochaine il sera également
question d'énergie au Sénat avec un
premier texte important au menu le
projet de loi qui est censé accélérer la
construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires et notamment les un réacteur
EPR 2 qui ont été promis par Emmanuel
Macron pendant la campagne
présidentielle et puis la semaine
suivante ce sera le projet de loi sur
l'organisation des Jeux Olympiques Paris
2024 avec beaucoup de mesures et de
questions sur la sécurité de l'événement
aussi des propositions
de loi initiatives de parlementaires
notamment la proposition de loi
anti-squate contre l'occupation illicite
de logements elle a été déposée par les
députés de la majorité présidentielle
adopter déjà par l'Assemblée nationale
mais après un débat très mouvementé dans
l'hémicycle du Palais Bourbon et la
majorité de droits de sénatoriales elle
ne devrait pas être hostile à ce texte
et elle pourrait même le durcir et puis
une autre proposition loi importante va
arriver au Sénat elle vient de
l'Assemblée nationale et elle prévoit
l'introduction dans la constitution du
droit à l'interruption volontaire de
grossesse un texte qui a été adopté par
une majorité de députés un majorité
présidentielle et également député de
gauche député de la nupes mais au Sénat
et bien la profitez de droite pourrait
rejeter ce texte et donc bloquer son
adoption car on le rappelle pour toute
révision de la Constitution il faut
l'accord du Sénat donc ça c'est pour le
mois de janvier et puis ensuite
arriveront les deux textes majeurs de ce
début d'année 2023 là réforme des
retraites ce sera plutôt en mars au
Sénat après l'adoption en février
l'examen en février par les députés et
puis avant il y aura le projet de loi
immigration ce sera et bien en février
au Sénat un premier examen pour les
sénateurs et justement Rémi Féraud on va
commencer par une question sur ce projet
de loi immigration on le rappelle le
gouvernement prévoit de régulariser les
travailleurs sans papiers dans les
métiers en tension est-ce que les
sénateurs socialistes pourraient voter
ce texte
façon on n'a pas les votes de posture on
vote sur les textes en fonction de leur
contenu donc on ne le connaît pas encore
on a beaucoup de mesures quand même on a
beaucoup de probable il n'y a pas que
cette mesure évidemment que vous veniez
d'évoquer mais sur cette mesure
un métier en tension des possibilités de
régularisation de travailleurs sans
papier c'est une question que je connais
bien j'ai été maire du dixième
arrondissement où cette question s'est
posée j'ai accompagné beaucoup de
combats pour la régularisation de
travailleurs sans-papiers c'est un point
sur lequel nous allons être évidemment
constructif mais cette
d'aborder
de voir ce que le gouvernement propose
vraiment et ce qui sortira vraiment de
la discussion
qui reviennent sur ce point que ce soit
tellement limitatif dans l'application
que cela ne change pas ne change pas
favorablement vraiment les choses mais
ça peut pas être l'arbre qui cache la
forêt d'un texte qui comme la réforme
des retraites est d'abord destinée à
obtenir le vote de Monsieur Ciotti avant
celui de la gauche donc voilà mais ça
n'est pas parce qu'on ne vote pas un
texte qu'on ne participe pas cette
discussion pour essayer de l'améliorer
cette question des travailleurs sans
papiers est en effet une question très
importante alors il y a une autre
position de loi à laquelle et bien la
gauche tient beaucoup elle va arriver au
Sénat en janvier c'est la promotion de
la constitutionnelle qui je le disais
introduit le droit à l'IVG dans notre
Constitution notamment pour éviter que
ce droit soit affaibli comme on l'a vu
aux États-Unis si la droite sénatoriale
rejette ce texte ce sera une erreur ah
oui chacun prend ses responsabilité je
pense que ils peuvent encore changer
d'avis bien sûr que ce serait une erreur
et leur argumentation pour un certain
nombre d'entre eux et de dire mais il y
a pas de danger donc pas la peine de
l'inscrire dans la Constitution ce qui
vient de se passer par exemple au Brésil
montre
qu'il faut jamais dire il y a pas de
danger bien sûr que si il y a un danger
et quand l'extrême droite progresse l'un
des points l'un des principes auxquels
elle s'attaquent toujours en premier
c'est justement le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
mais par exemple le rassemblement
national dit qu'il n'est pas en
favorable à l'abolition du droit à l'IVG
oui et ce qu'il faut le croire
ce sont en tout cas des déclarations
publiques est-ce qu'il faut le croire
moi je pense que
je ne vois pas les arguments qui
empêchent de l'inscrire dans la
Constitution à partir du moment où on
est attaché à son maintien et je crois
que croire l'extrême droite sur parole
voilà je le déconseille à qui que ce
soit un mot sur le nucléaire Rémy Ferro
avec ce projet de loi qui va accélérer
la construction de nouveaux réacteurs
nucléaires est-ce que les sénateurs
socialistes vont voter pour relancer le
secteur nucléaire là aussi je peux pas
vous dire si nous voterons ce projet de
loi nous n'avons pas encore qui n'a pas
encore été discuté ce qui est vrai c'est
que nous nous avons une approche
sur le fond mais aussi très pragmatique
nous pensons que le nucléaire est et
doit être une énergie de transition et
que l'important c'est
d'avoir un secteur nucléaire qui
permette de passer le cap des prochaines
décennies avec à la fois la sobriété
énergétique nécessaire et surtout du
développement des énergies renouvelables
c'est d'ailleurs pour ça que nous avons
voté le texte sur les énergies
renouvelables à l'automne quand je vous
dis que nous sommes constructifs c'est
ça qui nous paraît important et juste un
texte pour relancer le nucléaire pour
relancer le nucléaire sans faire
derrière les efforts nécessaires pour
passer le cap et n'en faire qu'une
énergie de transition alors évidemment
ça n'est pas du tout notre ligne
politique
puisque vous l'avez voté au Sénat les
députés sont appelés à le voter demain
est-ce que vous demandez aux députés
socialiste de le voter je souhaite qu'il
le vote et j'ai compris en tout cas
qu'il ne voteraient pas contre ce qui
montre oui tout à fait vous souhaitez
que votre peau ça franchement c'est leur
responsabilité mais je souhaite que ce
texte puisse être adopté merci Alex
merci à tout à l'heure on parlera et
forme des retraites évidemment on va
parler du Parti socialiste pour terminer
Rémi Féraud puisque les militants
socialistes sont appelés à voter les
deux jeudis qui arrivent pour désigner
le premier secrétaire trois candidats
sont en liste dont le premier secrétaire
sortant Olivier Faure que vous ne
soutenez pas pourquoi
c'est pas parce que je le soutiens c'est
que je soutiens Nicolas Mayer Rossignol
maire de Rouen qui porte un texte qui
s'appelle refondation c'est qu'on vient
du Parti socialiste donc paraître un peu
compliqué nos statuts mais nous votons
sur les textes d'orientation notre
orientation politique cette semaine sur
la personne du premier secretaire la
semaine la semaine suivante et je pense
que à la fois ce débat est très
important qu'il est
intéressant et que cette volonté
d'Olivier Faure de transformer l'accord
électoral nupes du printemps dernier en
un horizon politique indéspassable ça ne
me paraît pas la bonne voie la bonne
stratégie je pense qu'il faut réaffirmer
le Parti socialiste être dans l'union de
la gauche mais pas n'importe quel prix
et avec la perspect en même temps parce
que refondation on a l'impression que
c'est un peu en même temps on n'est pas
complètement contre la nuque mais on
n'est pas pour la nuque non plus à vous
parler comme Olivier Faure parce que
justement dans ce cas là on met la Nupe
au centre de tout or il faut mettre le
Parti socialiste et la capacité de la
gauche de se rassembler sur un projet et
sur des valeurs qui nous correspondent
qui permettent de fédérer et d'obtenir
une majorité l'objectif pour 2027 c'est
pas de construire une opposition qui
restera dans l'opposition même si
tout en existant c'est de construire une
coalition un projet politique qui soit
capable de gagner et la nups n'est pas
celui-là donc il faut pouvoir évoluer
sans tout casser et sans
refuser le principe même de l'union de
la gauche qui lui est essentiel et pour
ça c'est le problème c'est Jean-Luc
Mélenchon
bien sûr et un certain nombre de choses
que portaient les films et c'est surtout
le problème
le fait de ne pas vouloir sortir d'une
union de la gauche dominée par elle les
filles parce que cela c'est une
perspective qui est de toute façon une
perspective perdante donc
en réalité je pense qu'il est beaucoup
de gens
aux partis associés on a vu on est
d'accord sur la plupart des sujets de
fond il y a des désaccords stratégiques
il y a aussi des différences de
personnes de proposition d'organisation
moi j'ai vu au débat vendredi soir avec
Nicolas Maillard Rossignol quelqu'un qui
est à la hauteur de la fonction de
premier secrétaire s'il est élu et un
texte
refondation qui aspire aussi à
rassembler tous les socialistes qui est
un préalable aussi au rassemblement de
la gauche et dans ce débat entre les
trois candidats parmi les reproches fait
Olivier Faure il y a notamment celui qui
n'a pas assez travaillé est-ce que c'est
un reproche que reproche que vous
partagez oui mais qui ne s'adresse pas
qu'à Olivier fort qui doit être aussi un
reproche collectif
on ne peut pas repartir exactement comme
dans 5 années précédentes parce que
sinon rencontrera le même échec et par
ailleurs il ne faut pas qu'on construise
2027 en ne pensant qu'à refaire le match
de 2022 il faut vraiment s'inscrire dans
l'avenir et d'ailleurs
toutes les enquêtes l'actualité
politique l'évolution de la vie
politique le montre
nous sommes en 2023 nous ne sommes plus
en 2022 et l'appréciation des citoyens
des hommes et des femmes de gauche sur
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et les filles la
gauche je pense qu'il a déjà évolué
est-ce que si refondation ne remporte
pas le vote des militants socialistes
vous resterez quand même à l'intérieur
du parti socialiste parce que vous
souhaitez que fondation devienne un
parti à part un parti dissident
la question de se pose même pas et pour
les sénatoriales puisque les
sénatoriales arrivent notamment du côté
de Paris est-ce qu'il y aura des
candidats socialistes ou est-ce qu'il
pourrait y avoir des candidats
dissidents comme il y en a eu au
législatives j'espère qu'il y aura pas
de candidats dissidents c'est pas du
tout la même élection n'est pas dans le
même contexte d'ailleurs visuellement il
n'y a pas que les listes qui rassemble
l'ensemble des parties c'est une action
devant les grands électeurs qu'on avait
vecteurs sénatoriaux donc j'espère qu'il
n'y aura pas
des socialistes dissidents dont des
élections précédentes au sénatoriales à
Paris chez les socialistes en tout cas
pas dans les précédents élections
sénatoriales non et ça veut dire qu'il y
aura des candidats Unis est-ce que vous
pensez que cette élection à cette
élection interne l'élection à la tête du
premier secrétariat ça peut avoir des
conséquences sur le groupe ici au Sénat
je crois que non ça peut bien sûr parce
que la vie politique n'est pas
compartimentée bien sûr qu'il y a des
débats au groupe socialiste socialement
enfin nata reversé tellement d'épreuves
ensemble que je vous assure que nous
allons continuer y compris parce que sur
le fond nous sommes en accord nous avons
beaucoup de délibérations collectives et
vous remarquerez que nous votons
vraiment de manière unanime sur les
textes après avoir échangé ensemble
merci Rémi Féraud merci beaucoup d'avoir
été notre invité ce matin dans 20
minutes dans le territoire on reviendra
évidemment sur cette réforme des
retraites qui sera donc présentée demain
par Elisabeth borne et la majorité
présidentielle devrait donc pouvoir
compter sur le soutien des républicains
mais d'abord on va accueillir notre
chaîne invité c'est Stéphane séjourner
qui n'aurait jamais